if people aren't in shock and gasping
when you tell them how expensive your
thing is you're not going high enough
and the reason you say the first price
is extremely expensive is that without
trying people's brains will start to
justify how something could possibly be
that expensive now whether or not they
want to ultimately buy at that price you
fundamentally shifted how they're going
to see everything else you say in the
conversation so for example if I say one
dollar and then I say ten dollars boom
you have a range there now if I say a
thousand dollars and then I say ten
dollars it seems significantly different
and we want our price to be perceived
through the thickest richest money lens
possible so that it seems as small as
possible and as affordable and we
already want some of that
rationalization working in our favor so
that you can then go from the gasp to
the sigh of relief yeah I think I can
afford that